Diane Feinstein was fierce a political
force with a long list of Firsts Diane
who was the longest serving woman in the
Senate history had a career marked by
many first first woman to serve as mayor
of San Francisco first woman Senator to
represent
California first woman to serve as the
chair of the Senate intelligence commit
she was a historic figure Trailblazer
for women and a great friend Feinstein
became mayor of San Francisco after the
previous mayor and another member of the
government prominent gay rights activist
Harvey mil were assassinated she felt
for his pulse and found a bullet hole
both Mayor
Moscone and supervisor Harvey
Milk have been shot and killed that
trauma she said spurred her to fight for
gun control spearheading the legislation
in 19 1994 that banned many military
style assault weapons it expired 10
years later but after the Sandy Hook
massacre took the lives of 20 small
children and six adults in 2012 she
tried again but failed as the powerful
chairman of the Senate intelligence
committee Feinstein was controversial
supporting surveillance programs and
targeted assassinations carried out by
drones but she later took on the CIA it
Chronicles a stain on our history that
must never be allowed to happen again
this is not what Americans do she pushed
for an investigation into the torture
the CIA carried out against at least 119
people insisting that the torture didn't
work and then fighting to make sure the
world knew what they did her role later
highlighted in the movie The report I
would like us to be more than the
country that did the report I'd like us
to be the country that made it public
and that is what I intend to see happen
as the flag at the capital was lowered
to half staff her colleagues came out to
offer tributes but to her
constituents you need to know we
depended on her just as you did and she
was here every day to fight for you no
matter what she fought for women she
fought for those who were victims of gun
violence a mentor to many who will be
remembered as a woman who made a
difference over Decades of work
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer